le constat est sans appel la flambée des
prix de l'énergie est préoccupante et
elle commence à peser sur le budget des
français le prix du gaz et de
l'électricité ne cesse d'augmenter
depuis de nombreuses années il a doublé
en dix ans pour le prix du gaz et a
connu une hausse de 50 % pour
l'électricité sur la même période la
ministre avait parlé en 70 d'une hausse
autour de 12% est en fait le bouclier
tarifaire qui a été mise en place par le
par le gouvernement va limiter cette
hausse à 4 % mais on est quand même dans
une tendance haussière sur les années
futures face à cela l'aide de saint
quentin en yvelines implantée à montigny
le bretonneux propose des solutions
notamment au niveau des travaux de
rénovation énergétique la structure met
en avant une démarche dite de type
négawatt c'est vraiment d'aller vers une
économie zéro carbone mais qui s'axe sur
trois principal levier d'abord la
sobriété c'est à dire consommer
l'énergie uniquement là où elle est
nécessaire ne pas gaspiller l'énergie
l'efficacité avoir des équipements qui
fonctionnent bien voilà se chauffer la
chaudière va rendre ce service m'avoir
une une chaudière qui est efficace et
qui ne gâche pas de l'énergie et ensuite
essayer de développer au maximum les
énergies renouvelables pour produire
cette énergie l'énergie la moins chère
c'est celle qu'on ne consomme pas déjà
donc au niveau des des travaux qu'on
peut faire ça va être des travaux
d'isolation thermique de changement
d'équipements vétustes de vieilles
chaudières vieux radiateurs à deux
changements de vitrages l'association
sensibilise également aux éco gestes des
changements d'habitudes simple et du
quotidien qui tendent à limiter la
hausse de consommation réduire d'un
degré la température de consigne du
thermostat on va pouvoir faire autour de
7 % d'économies
ensuite bien régler la température de
son frigo vanot essayer de faire à 4
degrés
4° minimum voilà on va pouvoir
économiser et également vérifié au
niveau du congélateur qu'on n'a pas trop
de givre dès qu'on a dû vivre ça à faire
des surconsommations l'alec réalise sur
rendez-vous des bilans thermiques
propose des améliorations et oriente
vers des professionnels des initiatives
bienvenues pour freiner la hausse de
l'énergie